first of all what do you make of all
this madness because you said on the
show that a gt2 use like a boys club
ladies a boys club you know Simon owns
the show he can do whatever he wants he
owns it it's his show he can work with
whoever he wants and Simon historically
has when he works on the show he
constantly changes the people on the
panel so he does it with all his shows
in England and here he does it all the
time and he's got the right to do it
what do you make of Howard Stern
slamming Simon on his radio show it's
the way he feels I agree with a lot of
it and he's got the right to say what he
feels the same as Simon's got the right
to do whatever he wants on his show and
it's true it's his show listen if you
own something and you it's you you want
to work with people who you want to work
with he wants to change everybody all
the time
do it it's his show do you think he
recycles the women over and over again
that he wants younger fresher women
always and I don't think it served him
well in the past
I just don't but that's my opinion and
I'm entitled to my opinion
so it's you know you can you know you
can have you know the hottest newest
taste in town but it doesn't mean
they're right for your panel so then
what do you make of this mess with
Gabriele do you think that she it's
she's right in what she's saying or is
it listen I was never there when
Gabriele was there and you know I think
I said yesterday everybody's experience
working on the show is different I love
the show I loved the crew
I loved everybody on the panel I just
had an absolute blast on the show
you said it was like a boys club where
they're like it because she mentioned
inappropriate jokes and stuff like that
was that going on while you were there
jokes were probably made by me and when
I was there because I've got the potty
mouth so I would always say filthy
things to Howard yes I've got its mouth
and yeah I would I'm the one that's
always inappropriate but we love it you
once said that Simon fired you from the
vote England England because you were
you were old Youngblood and he got young
blood and the ratings went down not
saying that they were checking in for me
not saying that but is sometimes as I
keep saying the newest bestest taste in
town isn't always right for his sort of
shows gabriel's I'm gonna meet with
producers would advice do you have for
her and respectfully
that's her journey and that's her story
if you were her would you go back she
should go make another movie she's great
at acting but she probably doesn't want
to go back I mean I don't know I I
shouldn't speak for her if you think all
this flak will hurts I'm no Simon can do
what he wants
seriously and I'm not saying that in a
passive aggressive way it's his it's his
thing he's earned the right to sit next
to whoever he wants to sit next to and
that's it you know that's that's the
industry we work in
that's what everybody's not is missing
in a sense they're missing that yeah
right and people have to realize when
they say that you know oh you can't let
me go I'm so important no because we are
all there's somebody else waiting for
that seat and somebody else and somebody
else younger pretty and newer and that's
the industry we're in so you know that
going into it
nothing's permanent nothing doesn't mean
Gabriel one great it was just that's
though she loved guy she's the most
beautiful woman I thought she was great
just not my show you know I'm hired had
the same as years did he smoke on set
it's more of course Simon smokes on set
he was born with a bloody cigarette in
his mouth I have never seen him when he
doesn't walk with his cigarettes a
lighter and the nose thing he sticks up
his nose to clear his sinuses that's
silent he's not the only one but he
probably is the only one I've ever
worked with it that smokes in a building
or wherever he wants it's Simon it's his
show he can set himself on fire if he
wants you know and so he can smoke a
pipe a cigar that Simon if you don't
like it
[Music]